[Música]
a vida lá não tem equilíbrio
sou equilibristas essa é uma frase do
winick que pra mim diz muito do que é
saúde mental saúde mental então é o modo
como a gente tem as nossas loucuras
nossas maluquices
mas ao mesmo tempo a gente tem que andar
na rua a gente tem que olhar para a
direita para a esquerda antes de
atravessar a rua e não viu o caminhão
passa em cima ea gente morre mas é
impossível a gente pensar que saúde
mental conceito sólido não é
então eu vou talvez começar falando
exatamente da minha saúde mental ou seja
o modo como eu perdi minha saúde mental
e foi a partir daí que o pude fazer essa
pergunta do que é loucura
além das grades à loucura na cidade
não me lembro que era eu era na época um
jovem cirurgião cardíaco
vinte e poucos anos e eu me lembro como
hoje que era assim a uma cirurgia de
aneurisma de aorta
eu estava ali uma cirurgia longa né em
algum momento a realidade fugiu pra mim
completamente
eu não comecei mais acreditar nos meus
pensamentos eu percebi que os meus
pensamentos não fazia muito sentido
começar a questionar o sentido da vida
isso foi deixando um estado muito ruim a
ponto de eu inclusive não conseguir ver
aquele futuro brilhante como cirurgião
cardíaco eu queria as questões com a
minha própria loucura foi aumentando
procure um profissional
e aí eu conheci de uma certa maneira o
pior que eu fui parar no hospital
psiquiátrico
não fui parar no hospital psiquiátrico
passei muito tempo nesse hospital
psiquiátrico
e aí eu vi o sofrimento e como as
pessoas se apagam quando estão dentro do
hospital psiquiátrico
não é isso durante a 58 tempo pensei em
fugir
então eu falava pra minha família eu
falava pra todo mundo que estava à minha
volta não vou fugir desse hospital eu
vou fugir do hospital ela tinha um
problema meu é do diretor do hospital é
eu eu tinha sido convidado desencantei
com a desencantei com a cirurgia foi sic
atrás e psiquiatra eu também me encantei
com a psiquiatria eu fosse ficar na
lista
exatamente porque achei que a
psiquiatria ela não dava que mais a
gente queria que a necessidade de ouvir
o louco ouvir a loucura
a partida inclusive de uma de uma outra
relação que fosse aquela relação de
objeto louco ali eu costumo dizer que
tem gente que tem tanto medo tanto medo
de louco que vida psicólogo psicanalista
e psiquiatra
não é então na verdade o que é essa
minha longa internação no hospital
psiquiátrico há 67 anos na frente do
hospital
a pergunta que ficava pra mim era um
pouco como fazer do louco uma sombra
como é que vocês transformam louco numa
sombra apagada numa instituição dentro
das grades
a gente pode dizer que a gente
transforma um louco numa sombra quando a
gente mantém desnecessariamente trancado
em um hospital psiquiátrico
você imagina por exemplo o que seria uma
menina que nos seus 15 16 anos mais ou
menos ela tem primeiro surto psicótico
ela pega rompe com a vida toda com a
escola rompe com a família e aí ela vai
parar no hospital asilar com 30
pacientes às vezes crônicos não é muito
ruins e vocês ainda querem que ela saia
melhor do que entrou
eu desafio vocês já passaram um mês
internado em um hospital psiquiátrico e
ver se sai melhor do que entrada é muito
difícil
a gente também o silencia quando a gente
permite ficar lisa ou seja quando a
gente acha que só o remédio funciona ea
gente não escuta e acha que tem que
fazer a medicar
a gente também cuido subestima a
inteligência do louco que está na nossa
frente
eu me lembro de um colega ele estava
numa emergência psiquiátrica e paciente
na frente de victor tem aquele monstro
ali eu estou com muito medo daquele
monstro meu colega disse assim fique
tranquilo estou vendo mas ele está ele
não vai fazer nada com você
na mesma hora o paciente ó o doido aqui
isso wilson está vendo nada só está
querendo enganar
só quem vê aquilo ali sou eu também
uma das maneiras de silenciar ou louco é
reduzindo a loucura um problema
biológico não é cada vez mais se fazia
isso
o instituto nacional de saúde mental dos
estados unidos por exemplo têm uma verba
para pesquisa de um bilhão e meio ano
90% dessas pesquisas são para achar a
causa genética endócrina a célula é o
que eles vão chamar e dos índices das
neurociências e praticamente nada é
realmente feita a gente pensa na clínica
é como a gente lida com eles
claro a gente também contrata um louco
como um cidadão de segunda classe que
não tem direito a nada a gente reserva
pra ele pior que a sociedade faz muito
isso
espantando estuprando amarrando e
matando o brasil foi condenado pela
organização dos estados americanos
exatamente porque houve um uma morte no
hospital psiquiátrico né e em caicó
esse paciente estava contido no leito e
foi encontrado morto todo queimado e
óbvia não pode fugir da cama porque ele
estava amarrado se imagina então quanto
ele deve ter gritado e ninguém ouviu se
imagina não quer você está amarrado na
cama psique
pegando fogo e ninguém viu foi achado
morto depois ainda com as faixas
a gente também silencia quando o disco
louco é violento
quando a gente sabe que escancaradamente
né
os crimes são cometidos muito mais pelos
ditos ãos basta ver as taxas de
criminalidade
a gente percebe isso ou seja não dando a
mínima para o piloto fala né
eu passei a escutar loucos desde muito
cedo né e eu fui aumentando assim eu fui
escutando o clube em tudo que é canto do
elevador envolvendo a loucura do
ascensorista eu vou conversando com
alguém assim o seu centro alguém mais de
dez minutos eu fico perguntando fala é
loucura disse tá não apareceu ainda eu
não sei o que é mas a loucura é um
instrumento de de poder muito forte no
brasil por exemplo cravou capes
escravocrata é se diagnosticou adaptou
mania nos escravos é uma doença
psiquiátrica que fazia com que os
escravos tivesse vontade de fugir lado
ela tratado nem amarrado e colocado
tomando banhos frios tratamentos bem da
época né
em 1850 e tinham também uma doença
chamada de existência e típica é uma
doença estranha que faz com que o
escravo não consiga é entender o sentido
de propriedade e os patrões têm sobre
ele
não é hora
na verdade o modo propensa loucura é um
pouco diferente e aí eu vou convidar
vocês aquilo que sei e nem comigo um
pouquinho aqui vocês estão vendo aí e se
cuba mas percebo que vocês não estão
vendo esse clube na verdade vocês devem
estar vendo ou esse cuba à oea se cuba
não é isso
vocês até conseguem ver o um ou outro né
mas dificilmente consegue ver os dois
homens
o tempo a realidade é um pouco isso
ou seja ela nos dará welle nos dá um um
quadro simples e nós interpretamos a
nossa maneira e sempre a nossa maneira
ou seja não há uma realidade construída
comum é isso aí que parece com um cubo
parece uma bobagem não é tão bobagem
assim se vocês pensam por exemplo de um
primeiro plano o povo quer dizer fique
no avião
o segundo cuba quer dizer público
exatamente fora do avião e só aparece
isso na telinha do avião né
vocês vão ficar olhando não vão saber o
que fazer e vão ter que decidir pela
situação como vão ver a realidade que
vão como vocês vão tomar essa realidade
então a realidade ela sempre vai
depender do modo como a gente a ver quem
de vocês nunca entrou assim uma sala bem
seguro
olhou o programa disse que ele não foi
com a minha cara não é isso
ouvi vozes né dar um exemplo
é só vocês são assim uma reunião social
e que alguém estava em directo uma dura
assim diz conserta completamente fica
sem graça e não sabe o que fazer
vocês vão passar o resto da semana dando
a resposta certa na hora errada
não é isso vocês vão lembrar da cena epa
imaginar pessoas falam que vão dar uma
super resposta que vai destruir a pessoa
está falando você está dirigindo e de
repente se fala que a resposta chegue o
pai que é isso você tá tá doido está
falando sozinho
ou seja nós falamos o tempo inteiro
ouvimos vozes o tempo inteiro porque de
manhã com 6 acórdão painel para ir ao
banco
vocês falam hoje eu tenho que ir ao
é isso que falam basta senão ninguém
precisava falar a frase ou seja isso
nossa com todos nós temos lá nossas
aspirações né
mas o que acontece no mundo
contemporâneo é algo que parece muito um
case que quem dá publicidade conhece dos
anos 60
é mais ou menos o seguinte queria vender
muito bem difícil e aí fizeram campanha
para alavancar vendas
eles não conseguirão muito saber como
alavancar teve um cara genial falou você
quer realmente vender mais dentifrício a
bitola da bisnaga de meio milímetro que
você vai apertar mais a vitória vai ser
mais difícil acabar mais rápido e você
vai comprar outro mais rápido isso tartá
puxou as vendas da dessa empresa de
dentifrício é mais ou menos que estão
fazendo com a saúde mental hoje que
significa na hora que hoje em dia eu
recebi anos com 15 anos tiveram uma
briga com o namorado já se considerando
deprimidas e tomando antidepressivo
isso significa que o conselho de
depressão aumentou demais né
por exemplo a psiquiatria trabalha com
conceito atualmente se chama de espectro
significa que eu não sou
deprimido mas você está no espectro
depressivo
então vai tomar um antidepressivo eu
convido vocês faço uma aposta à hoje em
dia em um console de psiquiatria pagar
uma consulta e saída é uma receita
vocês podem ter nada a realização tem
nada não tem olha com o rivotril se você
precisar né não custa nada
então o que acontece na hora que se
trabalha com espectro autista respeito
da hiperatividade uma coisa muito doida
ou seja na minha época tinha quatro
canais de televisão os meninos têm 200
canais de televisão já nascem do outro
fazendo um self
eles têm o book eles têm computador ipod
e ipad cela usando dão e depois obrigou
a ficar quatro horas sentado na sala de
aula é dizem que ele é imperativa e da
sociedade cooperativa né e se ele recusa
tudo isso não então ele autismo ele não
quer saber de nada disso
então essa noção de espectro fez com que
em 1987
nos estados unidos em 1987 se consumia
800 milhões de dólares em medicamentos
sabe quanto em 2010 alguém aqui
simplesmente 40 bilhões de dólares são
consumidos e medicamentos nos estados
unidos e tudo uma promessa de felicidade
nem tão assim são remédios que vendem
uma coisa maravilhosa né
por exemplo vocês vão imaginar que tem
mais de 5 milhões de crianças são
diagnosticadas entre 2 e 17 anos como
tendo hiperatividade e o que eu acho
assim monstruoso mais de 10 mil crianças
foram identificadas já tomando remédios
na idade de dois a três anos para a
interatividade
vocês terem uma idéia da mata cidade da
coisa não é
então penso que os lucros foram às ruas
na eles foram pouco colocar voz dele nós
vamos perceber por exemplo que uma das
pacientes que está no projeto social
criar um mundo que eu criei pegou todos
os remédios que ela tomava e fez um
desfile de moda que foi muito bacana
saiu uma é uma grande cidade em torno
disso
e aí eu queria trazer para vocês uma
história para você entender um pouco que
foi certa vez atende uma senhora na
faixa dos 50 anos mãe de família dona de
casa legal
ninguém entende porque os 50 anos ativo
para uma emergência disse piada
e aí eu fui ouvindo aquela senhora e
descobri que há mais de 30 anos ela
tinha um delírio
digamos que ela achasse que ela era
selar a rainha da inglaterra ou lady
gaga madonna mariah de chegar você não é
madonna eu sou mandona você não é as
filas começaram assim nossa q vergonha
manhã dizendo que madonna a vizinhança
começar mais um mundo a começar negar a
ela que ela era a dona mas ela queria
provar o que aconteceria essa cpi e ela
é surpreendida numa rede de pesca de
peixe ea tarrafa uma rede que quando
pega se não
mas só dela que a rede de saúde mental
ela cairia nessa rede
só que ela era uma dona de casa que
delirava que era uma dona de casa
então quando se perguntava o que que na
zona falando não eu sou uma dona de casa
a gente mas você é realmente uma
dona-de-casa bons amigos um problema
nenhum
ela ficava ali exercendo a função dela
dona de casa não tinha problema nenhum
só lá os 50 anos de idade mais ou menos
que ela teve um problema de saúde e à
família fez muita pressão e insistiu e
acabou que e ela colocou uma uma
faxineira e na hora que essa faxineira
em tela diz compensa completamente
porque aí houve uma invasão do espaço
dela dona de casa porque eu trago esse
exemplo para que vocês percam a minha
esperança percam de uma vez por todas a
ilusão de que loucura tem a ver com a
normalidade ou seja a normalidade pode
ser um delírio com qualquer outro né
eu tenho paciência que chegou a dormir
sob a cadeia de normal né é isso mesmo
é claro que eles sabem isso faz sabe
andar naquela trama é difícil né de se
manter como equilibrista é com todos nós
um sinal né no sentido da vida e ele
soube mais ou menos só fale e não não
cair num certo abismo ou seja à
normalidade o que a gente pode pensar é
que contrariamente à loucura não é
aquilo que parece que é assim algo
grande espetacular ela pode ser muito
discreta e a tal ponto que eu realmente
penso assim todo mundo de uma certa
maneira
todo mundo é louco quando eu converso
com alguém eu converso com a maior
humildade porque eu não pergunto por
exemplo algum louco tempos encadeado
tenha furtado
eu não pergunto como a psiquiatria faz
diga-me você como você foi ficando louco
essa pergunta clássica da psiquiatria né
quando comecei começou a sentir um mundo
estranho como as coisas foram
organizando se começou a ouvir vozes a
pergunta que eu como psicanalista fácil
assim me diga você é só você pode me
dizer como é que se fazia para mantê lo
aquecido antes ao seu truque é como é
que você fazia para inventar um sentido
à sua vida e conseguiu ali ao fim o seu
delírio
eu passei assim eu só posso falar isso
quando eu sei das minhas maluquices
mas o que eu percebo é que de uma certa
maneira eu comecei falando para vocês da
extrema solidão da minha loucura
mc saída da cirurgia cardíaca e
simpática a atriz me desencantar e fez e
prática análise me fez querer escutar a
a loucura é que o site de uma solidão e
segundo as estatísticas mundiais
hoje eu tenho 7,2 bilhões de loucos para
me fazer companhia
né obrigado
[Aplausos]